elle peut aussi prédire le futur, y compris notre futur.
Quand on prend du recul,
on peut voir les astéroïdes dans leur milieu naturel,
en orbite autour du soleil.
Chaque point de cette simulation que vous pouvez voir
est un astéroïde réel.
Son orbite a été calculée à partir de son déplacement dans le ciel.
Les couleurs reflètent la composition des astéroïdes,
secs et minéraux au centre,
riches en eau et primitifs vers le bord,
des astéroïdes riches en eau qui pourraient avoir ensemencé
les océans et les mers que l'on trouve sur notre planète,
lorsqu'ils ont bombardé la Terre à une époque ancienne.
Le LSSTsera capable d'affiner son champ de vision,
et pas seulement de voir large,
nous pourrons donc voir ces astéroïdes
bien au-delà des régions intérieures de notre système solaire,
des astéroïdes au-delà des orbites de Mars et Neptune,
des comètes et des astéroïdes qui pourraient se trouver
presque à une année-lumière de notre soleil.
Et en grossissant les détails de cette image,
en les grossissant d'un facteur de 10 à 100,
nous pourrons savoir s'il y a des traces de planètes
au-delà de l'orbite de Neptune,
détecter les astéroïdes qui risquent de frapper la Terre
bien avant qu'ils ne soient un danger,
et de découvrir, peut-être,
si notre soleil s'est formé tout seul ou bien dans un groupe d'étoiles.
Peut-être est-ce ces compagnons stellaires
qui ont influencé la formation de notre système solaire,
et peut-être est-ce pour cela que les systèmes comme le nôtre
semblent si rares.
Les distances et les changements, dans notre univers...
La distance équivaut au temps,
tout comme les changements dans le ciel.
Chaque mètre de la distance où porte votre regard,
ou plutôt chaque mètre qui vous sépare d'un objet,
vous fait regarder près d'un milliardième de seconde dans le passé.
Ce concept, cette notion de regarder dans le passé
a révolutionné nos idées sur l'univers,
et plus d'une fois.
La première fois fut en 1929,
lorsqu'un astronome appelé Edwin Hubble
a montré que l'univers était en expansion,
ce qui a conduit à l'idée du Big Bang.
Et les observations étaient simples :
seulement 24 galaxies
et un schéma fait à la main.
Mais rien que l'idée que plus une galaxie est lointaine,
plus elle s'éloigne rapidement,
a suffi à donner naissance à la cosmologie moderne.
Une deuxième révolution s'est produite 70 ans plus tard,
lorsque deux groupes d'astronomes ont montré
que l'univers n'était pas seulement en expansion,
il accélérait,
une chose aussi surprenante que de jeter une balle en l'air
et de s'apercevoir que plus elle monte,
plus elle prend de la vitesse.
Ils ont montré cela
en mesurant la luminosité des supernovae,
et la façon dont cette luminosité
diminue avec la distance.
Ces observations étaient plus complexes.
Elles nécessitaient de technologies et de télescopes nouveaux,
parce que les supernovae étaient dans des galaxies
2 000 fois plus éloignées
que celles utilisées par Hubble.
Et ça a pris trois ans de trouver seulement 42 supernovae,
parce qu'il ne se produit qu'une explosion de supernova
tous les cent ans dans une galaxie.
Trois ans pour trouver 42 supernovae
en fouillant des dizaines de milliers de galaxies.
Et une fois les données rassemblées,
voici ce qu'ils ont trouvé.
Ça n'a l'air de rien, comme ça,
mais c'est à cela que ressemble une révolution en physique :
une ligne qui prévoit la luminosité d'une supernova
à 11 milliards d'années-lumière,
et une poignée de points qui ne sont pas sur la ligne.
Des petits écarts qui produisent de grandes conséquences.
Des petits écarts qui nous permettent de faire des découvertes,
comme la planète trouvée par Herschel.
Des petits écarts qui bouleversent
notre compréhension de l'univers.
42 supernovae, légèrement trop sombres,
ce qui veut dire légèrement plus loin,
ce qui implique que l'univers ne fait pas que s'étendre,
mais que cette expansion s'accélère,
et qui révèle un élément de notre univers
que nous appelons aujourd'hui l'énergie noire,
un élément qui alimente cette expansion,
et qui constitue 68 % de l'énergie
de notre univers.
A quoi ressemblera donc la prochaine révolution ?
Eh bien, qu'est-ce que l'énergie noire, et pourquoi existe-t-elle ?
Chacune de ces lignes représente un modèle différent
de ce que pourrait être l'énergie noire,
en faisant apparaître ses propriétés.
Chacun est cohérent avec les 42 points,
mais les idées qui les sous-tendent
sont radicalement différentes.
Certains pensent que l'énergie noire
évolue avec le temps,
ou bien que ses propriétés sont différentes
suivant la direction dans laquelle on regarde le ciel.
D'autres introduisent des changements
dans la physique au niveau subatomique.
Ou alors, ils voient les choses en grand,
et modifient la façon dont la gravité et la relativité générale fonctionnent,
ou bien ils disent que notre univers n'est qu'un parmi d'autres,
un élément de ce mystérieux multivers.
Mais toutes ces idées, toutes ces théories
stupéfiantes et, je l'admets, parfois un peu folles,
sont toutes cohérentes avec nos 42 points.
Comment alors pouvons-nous espérer y voir clair
dans les années à venir ?
Eh bien, imaginez que je vous donne une paire de dés,
et que je vous demande de déterminer
si ces dés sont truqués ou pas.
Un seul lancer de dés ne vous dirait pas grand-chose,
mais plus vous les lancez,
plus vous rassemblez de données,
plus vous sauriez avec certitude
non seulement s'ils sont truqués ou pas,
mais dans quelle mesure, et de quelle manière.
Il a fallu trois ans pour trouver seulement 42 supernovae
parce que les télescopes que nous avions construits
ne pouvaient explorer qu'une petite partie du ciel.
Avec le LSST, nous avons une nouvelle image complète
du ciel au -dessus du Chili toutes les trois nuits.
Lors de sa première nuit de fonctionnement,
il va trouver 10 fois plus de supernovae
que ce qu'il a fallu pour découvrir l'énergie noire.
Et ce nombre sera multiplié par mille
dans les quatre premiers mois :
1,5 milliard de supernovae à la fin de l'étude,
chaque supernova sera comme un lancer de dés,
et nous montrera un peu plus quelles théories de l'énergie noire
sont cohérentes, et quelles ne le sont pas.
Et ainsi, en combinant ces données sur les supernovae
avec d'autres mesures de la cosmologie,
nous éliminerons progressivement les différentes idées
et théories de l'énergie noire,
jusqu'à ce que, je l'espère, à la fin de cette étude, vers 2030,
on puisse espérer voir
une théorie de notre univers,
une théorie fondamentale de la physique de notre univers,
émerger progressivement.
A plus d'un titre, les questions que j'ai posées
sont en réalité tout ce qu'il y a de plus simple.
Nous ne connaissons peut-être pas les réponses,
mais au moins savons-nous comment poser les questions.
Mais si explorer des dizaines de milliers de galaxies
a révélé 42 supernovae qui ont bouleversé
notre compréhension de l'univers,
quand nous travaillerons sur des milliards de galaxies
combien de fois encore allons-nous trouver
42 points qui ne correspondent pas à ce que nous attendions ?
Comme la planète trouvée par Herschel,
ou l'énergie noire,
ou la mécanique quantique, ou la relativité générale,
toutes ces idées qui sont venues parce que les données
ne correspondaient pas à ce que nous attendions.
Ce qui est si enthousiasmant pour les prochaines années
dans les données en astronomie,
c'est que nous ne savons même pas combien il y a de réponses
qui nous attendent au tournant,
des réponses sur nos origines ou sur notre évolution.
Combien y a-t-il de réponses
aux questions que nous ne savons même pas
que nous voulons poser ?
Merci.
(Applaudissements)